it's a convenient response isn't it that
every time there is an Israeli strike on
some sort of facility inside Gaza you
just tell us that Hamas is operating
there and that's why you're fighting
back welcome to Black resin where we
redefine skincare try our squeaky clean
test promise for radiant skin our
exclusive shillig resin formula repairs
exfoliates and hydrates get that
refreshing glow also available as a face
wash elevate your skin care with black
resin your skin deserves the best use
weekly for results Link in the
description
box brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inah I
think finally BBC maybe finally have
come to their senses finally yeah to be
impartial finally finally or is it a
card they can use and say oh look we are
impartial there was that time we went
and said D D D D D let's see what we're
going to make out of it do you want to
watch the video Zan not really let's
watch it then it's a it's a convenient
response isn't it that every time there
is an Israeli strike on some sort of
facility inside Gaza you just tell us
that Hamas is operating there and that's
why you're fighting back we
understand here though is saying that
its facility the UN internationally
recognized body the UN says that its
facility in Gaza was attacked by your
forces overnight and this morning
reporting a significant number of deaths
the point is that is in contravention of
international humanitarian law and
people need somewhere that is safe to go
if you are telling them to evacuate from
the north of Gaza
I have to push back because the
insinuation in your question is that
Israel takes pleasure at taking pot
shots at civilian facilities that's 100%
correct Israel does take advantage and I
think enjoys doing that and to be honest
and to be frank forget us the Israel
settlers from the idea of soldiers to
the politicians to the prime minister to
the the defense minister to the rabbis
are saying the same thing I mean look at
this we must obliterate Hamas you see
and what Israel has to do which I'm
hoping of course they will is they are
going to what's called
raise Gaza they're going to destroy it
what is important to understand what the
logic of the war is based on the divine
plan there is no permission from the tah
to have any Mercy
whatsoever during war not on children
not on women not on anybody but the
point is right here that hasem say do
not have mercy on the children kill all
their children also why there's no
difference between them and their
children in 10 years from now these
children will attack you on the
way knows God knows here we're not
playing by your rules we're playing by
the rules of the Torah what a
compilation that's a scathing video bro
exactly I mean if you think about it and
there are certain individuals who um
work is it canet canet the canet yeah
yeah yeah like certain rabbis who have
outright said this so this is something
directly linked to the Torah and they
are using that to Advantage I mean some
people can read that and interpret that
maybe in a different way but they're
definitely interpreting as you know what
yes you take out everyone men women
children baby look amalik in the book of
the Old Testament this is mentioned over
and over again well they're definitely
using it doesn't mean the Torah is
calling for the indiscriminate killing
of men women and children but these
people are definitely taking that
reading from the Torah so yeah these
videos bro I honestly don't know what to
say after seeing it I did see like one
of them but I mean and that video you
only played like half of it yeah exactly
more there's more and um that that's
very worrying to be honest and it's
funny how in all of the media coverage
that we've seen so far no credible
political analyst or no newspaper has
put on the front page oh the Torah this
or the Judaism needs to be reformed or
this or that in fact I haven't come
across it even once now the question is
whenever something happens you know
certain Muslims will justify using the
Quran it will be all over the media BBC
will be debating it left right center
OBC all of these guys but my question is
why not here exactly why not they
usually have a field day with the
Muslims and we you wouldn't have a vast
majority of reputable Scholars Who come
out and justify the kingom of innocent
people they are outright quoting verses
and by the way there are no verses in
the Quran or the Sunnah anywhere that
directs you to kill innocent men women
and children there are Biblical verses
in the Old Testament which do say that
now you can interpret that was God
commanding that in that time they're
using those direct words and no one's
saying you know the Torah has to be
changed this a book of violence of
terrorism and this that not only that
they are actually outright enacting on a
state level what you think about the BBC
and I I was very impressed with that guy
who actually used that word like oh how
convenient I was actually I think they
didn't feel he lost his job maybe I I
think you know what it's just
frustration because we've been hearing
this since day one the schools being
attacked the hospitals being attacked
the mosque's been attacked oh Hamas was
there Hamas was there Hamas was there
it's just getting a bit you know what I
mean like people are like we've seen the
evidence that Hamas was that was a
refugee camp yeah the UN one that was a
un refugee camp mate yeah oh no but
Hamas what's the evidence the BBC in
another clip were pushing back there
there was there's no evidence that Hamas
is holding fuel as said by the you know
one of the organizations you know what's
really really confusing I haven't come
across a single country or a single Army
try weak easel their way out of bombing
a hospital yeah this is the first
instance that I've seen where they're
actually trying to convince us that you
know what there were terrorists under
that hospital mate yeah that's that yeah
they had tunnels under there mate yeah
that's what they okay were they
underneath or were they above if they're
underneath then why are you shooting at
the hospital yeah if they're in the
hospital why don't you listen to this
not shoot at the hospital exactly it's
not rocket science is it and you know
what's really funny is that when the CNN
went there to the IDF that showed them
they found four AK-47s and a motorbike
and I'm just thinking to myself so Hamas
has nowhere else to put these four
AK-47s and a motorbike yeah it's good
you remember the motorbike yeah I had to
cuz he had apparently a bullet mark on
it here so H is using the bottom of the
hospital and none of these people in the
hospital have any clue I mean come on
you can't make this stuff up it just
shows their desperation they're getting
more desperate because whole world it's
entitlement bro it's entitlement it's
the fact that they've been allowed to do
what they want frankly for you know well
over half a century backed by NATO
backed by the west and you know what
NATO is us well it's definitely an
extension but the fact that now they're
actually being held to account because
this is the most mobilized we've seen to
my knowledge the world against the
atrocities that are being committed to
the people of Gaza in fact here in the
UK Saturday alone was the biggest March
that we've seen to datee yeah yeah
exactly so people people are definitely
wising up it it's just becoming boring
Hamas is the oh Hamas is there in the
school therefore just blow up like a
thousand kids like it's just becoming
like even a rational person even if
you're Pro Israeli you're going to be
like you know what like that's a bit of
a Mad R how am I going to defend that
but they just Hamas Hamas is under there
like it's just weird in in sisters
Israel is losing this war both on it's
not just these marches were not just
done by Muslims there were thousands
hundreds of thousands of non-muslims are
seeing the atrocities and Israel is
losing this war so much so that we are
seeing them buying ads again on our
YouTube channels and different YouTube
channels carry on you guys doing an
amazing job yeah why would you buy ads
if you know what people can just see
right from wrong mate yeah you got the
power you've got the Western media
behind you it's still not cutting it
mate working I mean it's just not doing
the job frankly exactly Israel you're
finished you're finished and you are
finished inshallah the whole world is
seeing your oppression and genocide
you're doing and the whole world will
remember you as that till next
time